وتعليقا على اعلان المرشح الرئاسي للجوله
الاولى سنان اوغن دعمها الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان في الجوله الثانيه قال زعيم حزب
الشعب الجمهوري والمرشح الرئاسي عن تحالف
الشعب كمال كالجدار اوغلو انه بات من
الواضح من يقف الى جانب هذا الوطن الجميل
ومن يقف الى جانب من يبيعوا على حد تعبير
واضاف في تغريده على تويتر ان تحالفه قادم
لانقاذ تركيا من الارهاب ومن اللاجئين كما
قال ودعا كالجدار اوغلو المواطنين والشبان
الذين لم يتوجهوا الى صناديق الاقتراع
والبالغ عددهم ثمانيه ملايين شخص للمشاركه
في التصويت
من جانبه وقبل كشف سنان اوغانا عن موقفه
دعا مرشح تحالف الشعب المعارض كمال
كالجدار اوغلو الى التصويت بكثافه في
الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات الرئاسيه
لا يهم اذا كنت تحبني ام لا فانا اقبل ذلك
ولكن اذا كنت تحب اولادك فعليك ان تقرر لا
تنسى ان هذا اليوم ليس من اجل فقط بل من
اجل ابنائكم من يحب هذا الوطن فليصوت
وليمارس حقه بالاقتراع